euh je vais d'abord rencontré un cousin
et moi je vous le dit qui voilà qui fait
de la danse qui fait du chant qui va
révolutionner
voilà le monde de la danse et du chant
il adore michael jackson il adore
francky vincent
regardez c'est michael jackson qui fait
alors vous allez adorer francky jackson
avec alice ça glisse
m
oui
mais je sortais causés aux fruits de la
passion réciproque een pa ti franck et
vas-y francky c'est bon quand il va s'y
trompe pas si francky pas si francky
c'est bon tu pue du cul
[Musique]
et en bonus track la version
bouleversante de tu veux mon zizi tu
veux mon zizi oui oui
[Musique]
tu veux
l'idée
oui
oui oui
bangui jackson prochainement en galère
ça jardel et 3 cochet à la maison de
retraite
isabelle morini bosc et michael jackson
soit bien sûr si mon café sont à eux
voient comment ça qu'est ce qui se passe
là les mecs quoi ça fait tous en douze
ans que je me fais chier à mettre de
l'huile de jojoba là dessus mais tu
reconnais baraka jackson ah c'est ça
voyez pas que l'on transfère la merde
tout bon monsieur beauzac ou parce que
la restonica coule pas à coup sûr qu'on
n'a pas reconnu je n'avais pas que j'ai
12 ans qui travaille avec moi on se
réservait pour le 12 mars ça qui paye
lui
[Applaudissements]
je sais que les téléspectateurs aiment
beaucoup ces petits maison sachez que là
vous voyez le produit fini mais ça n'a
pas été si facile de le faire
regardez mais ça n'a pas été si facile
[Applaudissements]
je suis là de faits divers
merci à vous